brussels in crisis mode yet again the
rau over the e use plan to send refugees
back to Turkey already in full swing
despite leaders voicing support at the
EU council we support the idea of
turning back people from the Greek
islands back to Turkey that is a good
idea human rights activists on the other
hand are sounding the alarm bells in
Brussels they fear that a deal with
turkey could result in mass deportations
turkey can't be considered a safe
country not only because there's a large
cove of human rights violation in Turkey
but also because even when you look at
only if I may say so the Geneva
Convention they're not respecting that
at all but not only turkey also the
situation on the Greek Macedonian borden
a domain E is a concern for European
leaders more than 10,000 refugees are
stranded here in dire conditions it will
have to face a humanitarian crisis
because of the unilateral actions in the
Balkan route and the thing that this is
a shame for our common culture with all
that hanging in the balance German
Chancellor Angela Merkel expressed
slight concerns no complete theater 400
complicated negotiations but the basic
direction is clear I agree with council
president us who said is cautiously
optimistic with the emphasis on kasha
optimistic Schmidt patron of was HD
leaked everybody is expecting a long
night in Brussels and the work continues
when Turkish Prime Minister Ahmet
Davutoglu joins the negotiations on
Friday morning